pour levallois serge sérieusement est-ce
que vous pensez que en étant parti dans
les conditions qu'on connaît en revenant
en nous faisant élire
est-ce que vous pensez que vous aidez la
politique
en agissant de la sorte mais moi je je
ne cherche pas aidé la politique je
cherche à aider la ville dans laquelle
je travaille depuis tant d'années a
progressé à aller de l'avant
j'essaye d'aider les levalloisiens moi
j'ai fais de la politique pour aider les
autres pour servir uniquement comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure je n'avais pas
besoin de faire la politique
je suis né dans une famille où on avait
tout ce qu'il fallait
il y avait une affaire il y avait tout
ce qu'il fallait je n'avais vraiment pas
besoin de politiques pour gagner de
l'argent comme certains voudraient le
laisser dire laissé entendre
moi j'ai fait la politique vraiment par
conviction et je continue à faire de la
politique
j'envie si j'avoue dévoué finalement
pour levallois s'est pas votre intérêt
personnel c'est pour la ville assad et
ça l'a toujours été et ça continuera à
l'être et mon épouse aussi et votre
action notre tour notre élection pour
l'image de la politique des hommes
politiques français
c'est bénéfique vous savez je sais pas
si l'image des hommes politiques est
aussi bénéfique pour moi en tout cas je
m'arrache je me rends compte d'une chose
c'est que sans investiture je suis élu
d'autres avec les investitures de tous
les partis ne sont pas et du très bien
on rallume